do you think I could pull off dark
Academia
no
what about uh Cottage core
we are not doing this again fine maybe
you like me haven't found your perfect
aesthetic yet or maybe you got a new job
or you've hit that summer in your 20s or
you have eight different weddings to go
to for whatever reason you want a whole
new wardrobe and you want it right now
no problem you can open up a new Shane
tab or hit your local h m and walk out
with 10 different outfits for under 200
bucks that seems better than spending
thousands of dollars you don't have on
designer clothes but what happens to
that closet full of new outfits a year
from now what about in a month
[Music]
thank you
foreign
have long detailed the industry's
environmental costs and unsavory labor
practices but Americans still spend an
average of Seventeen hundred dollars per
year on cheap new clothes so how did
fashion start cycling through our
wardrobes and our wallets so fast as
recently as the 1980s most fashion
brands brought out new collections two
to four times a year giving consumers
New pieces to buy with the changing of
the seasons the average American bought
about 12 New pieces of clothing annually
but in order to increase their profits
clothing companies wanted to figure out
how to get Shoppers to buy more they
figured out two reliable ways to do that
lower prices and more options by the
early 2000s fashion brands like Zara h m
and Forever 21 figured out that they
could increase the demand for new
clothing items by making more of them
instead of coming out with clothes twice
a year they were putting new items on
their retail floors every two weeks and
the cheaper the items the more
comfortable Shoppers would be with
making another fashion haul in order to
keep prices low and profits High fast
fashion retailers started skimping out
on everything from the wages of the
people who sew your garments to the
quality of the fabric and construction
everything from the way they cut pattern
pieces to the zippers and buttons they
use is designed to keep production costs
as low as possible these frequent
collections also warp our perspective on
how much clothing is enough yes everyone
wears something to work every day at
least we hope but fast fashion retailers
want us to feel like we need to go all
in on the latest Tick Tock aesthetic
even if the trend will already be passe
by the time our order arrives the pace
of fast fashion has escalated so much
that online retailers like Shane now put
thousands of new items on their site
every day and the average American by 68
new items a year we also throw away way
more clothes because Brands cut so many
corners to keep prices low your clothes
are literally built to fall apart and
all the better for fast Fashion's bottom
line if consumers buy into the idea that
their clothes are disposable they'll
keep coming back to buy more who cares
if it's so affordable right well it's
not affordable to the people making your
clothes as Aja Barber writes in her book
consumed about the impacts of fast
fashion the average garment worker can't
afford to buy the clothes she makes
retailers like Shane regularly come
under Fire for violating labor laws in
their factories where garment workers
put in 16-hour days generally making
about four cents per finished item of
clothing and it's not affordable for the
planet either according to the EPA
Americans throw out over 11 million tons
of textiles every year that's five times
what we tossed out in the 80s now fast
fashion makes up eight percent of the
world's greenhouse gas emissions in the
cycle from production to landfill
because the trend Cycles are moving so
fast and the clothing is made poorly
your fast fashion likely can't be
donated or even worn for more than a few
wears it's just trash the low prices of
fast fashion obscure the true cost to
workers consumers and the environment
but even if fast fashion wasn't bad for
the people or the planet it can still be
pretty disastrous for your wallet in our
episode about how it's expensive to be
poor we talked about how buying the
cheapest option can cost more in the
long run and that's true here too if you
buy the average number of fast fashion
pieces a year about 68 and spend 20
dollars per item over five years you
will have spent six thousand eight
hundred dollars on clothes maybe more if
you put all those clothes on a credit
card you can't pay off or bought them
using a buy now pay later service if you
return to the average number of garments
someone bought in the 1980s you could
even spend four times as much money per
piece on higher quality items and over
five years you'll have spent two
thousand dollars Less on clothes overall
and because you bought clothes that last
by now you've got just as many items as
the average fast fashion Shopper how can
more expensive clothing turn out to be
cheaper consider cost per wear by
dividing the price of a clothing item by
the number of times you'll use it a
fifteen dollar dress you wear twice
works out to seven dollars each time you
wear it meanwhile a 100 dress that lasts
you three dozen wears comes out to less
than three dollars per wear fast fashion
seems more affordable in the short term
but even though it feels like you're
getting way more clothes you're getting
a lot less value out of them so what can
you do instead first buy less and buy
better building a wardrobe you love is a
marathon not a Sprint so take your time
when you shop and learn to check seams
hems Linings and other details that help
you know if a garment is built to last
higher prices don't always mean the
Garment is better made but if you want
to splurge on some higher quality items
you get more out of your clothing budget
if you buy fewer pieces per year buying
less might mean you feel left out when
everyone else is having their disco
pants era but the whole reason Trends
exist in the first place is because
clothing manufacturers are churning out
new items and running ads and pushing
sponsored content into your feeds to get
you to spend more of your money remember
you don't have to buy into every Trend
in order to have personal style my
personal favorite solution is buying
second hand it lets you divert someone
else's waste from the landfill in the
process of getting you your new bit and
for special events or costume parties
consider borrowing or renting rather
than buying a fancy outfit you only plan
to wear once and finally treat the
clothes that you have with care even if
you already own fast fashion taking good
care of your clothes gives them a longer
lifespan read those annoying little
labels so you know when to hand wash
delicate items or hang things to air dry
watch YouTube tutorials and learn how to
do basic mending like fixing a loose hem
sewing on a button or patching a hole
visible mending techniques that use
colorful thread or fun patches are also
a great way to update an old item for a
new look lots of Shoppers say they buy
fast fashion because they want to have
fun with their clothes without spending
too much money and we get it no matter
what your budget you deserve to love the
clothes you wear but to get there we all
need to treat our wardrobes like
Treasures not like trash
and that's our two cents all this month
PBS is releasing new digital series and
specials celebrating Earth month one in
particular we'd like to highlight is
above the noises new episode on E-Waste
the term for when Electronics reach the
end of their life cycle the episode
covers their environmental impact and
explores things consumers can do about
it check out the link in the description
for it for the rest of PBS's Earth month
playlist thanks
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
[Music]